we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
really important topic
in today's voicemail
these nebulous
nine-month abortions
okay the right
is in a frenzy
over supposed nine month abortions
listen to the voicemail then we'll
discuss
hi david i just had a quick question
i keep hearing from uh stephen crowder
and
lauren bover and other people that
there's a nine month you can have a
nine-month
abortion in there in colorado i was just
wondering if that is an anecdote or if
it's just hyperbole or if it's rhetoric
uh your thoughts on this would be much
appreciated okay
um something like 91 of abortions happen
extremely early i forget the exact
number of weeks but
very very early 91
and then the other 9
almost all of those happen
in an intermediate period of the
pregnancy
typically now we're talking about for
medical reasons
now what the right has seized upon
is that there are some states
that don't put a limit
of gestational age
legally on when an abortion could be
done so what the starting point for this
claim that oh you can you can be
39 weeks pregnant
walk in and say i'd like an abortion and
everybody's gonna say sure sure okay
what it stems from is that there are
certain states that don't put a number
of weak limit on abortions legally
speaking now
obstetricians have weighed in on this
endlessly and they have all said
recently under oath in congressional
testimony this does not happen when you
have an abortion at the extraordinarily
late stage of an abortion of a pregnancy
that is being discussed
it is
essentially
aside from being so so rare
it's because a genetic abnormality is
found in the fetus
that that makes evident that this is not
going to be able to be
a person that survives either at all or
for more than some
minuscule amount of time outside of the
womb horrible horrible situations
genetic abnormalities and other things
uh an extraordinarily difficult decision
is made
um at that point to to essentially
accelerate by what might be
days or a couple of weeks would it what
is inevitably going to be a non-viable
pregnancy horrible situation extremely
rare other situation is it is determined
that there is a um a situation that
endangers the life of the mother
okay
these are
insanely rare situations that do
sometimes happen
that are very difficult for the pregnant
women and their families
and
are not what the right loves to dream up
which is
a woman decides on week 39
five days before the 40-week mark or the
due date you know what i just don't want
the baby could we do an abortion and obs
have already testified it never happens
but if someone did come in and they are
essentially full term
and said i don't want the baby let's do
an abortion obs have said we wouldn't do
it we would say well this is a full-term
baby like we could we can do if there's
a problem with a pregnancy we could do a
c-section and then
we could look at adoption if you're not
you know we're
this is an imaginary situation that the
right has dreamed up that almost does
not happen so the origins of it are
there are states that don't enshrine by
statute a limit on the number of weeks
for abortions
that doesn't mean women are walking in
two days before their due date and
saying i'd like an abortion for no
medically relevant reason i just don't
want the baby doesn't happen obs have
explained it it's a red herring it's not
even really relevant to the abortion
debate which again
these right wingers who say oh people
are walking in at nine months
they're often also opposed to abortions
at five weeks
so don't even be tricked into thinking
that this is really even the issue for
them
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today speaking of abortion
how are women now in certain states that
are
have or will be banning abortion
altogether
how are they going to obtain
abortion pills
that are or will be banned there's
already an entire infrastructure being
put in place to try to support women
in those situations and in those states
second
democrats are increasingly saying to joe
biden
you do have some authority to take major
steps towards cannabis legalization you
can't just say recreationally legal
everywhere but there are steps joe biden
can take what about doing that we will
talk about it and number three
drag queens are now the new target of
intimidation by the far right as i
tweeted this morning there are lots of
right wingers who seem to think drag
queens and trans people are
interchangeable terms
they are not
and it might not come as a shock to many
of you that right wingers are confused
about some things and we will talk about
that on the bonus show as well sign up
at
joinpackman.com you can get instant
access by signing up on our website you
can also get a discount off of the price
of membership by using the coupon code
big voting 22. i look forward to
welcoming you into the ranks of
membership i also will be streaming live
saturday night the trump rally in alaska
this will be a doozy i hope you'll join
me on youtube twitch and or facebook
and otherwise we'll be back with a new
show tomorrow